la foire de l'état du minnesota attire
chaque année deux millions de personnes
à l'été 2010 8,1 mais en particulier
fait fureur
un sandwich blt suspect de kenza une
céréale peu connu
or cet aliment pourrait à lui seul
transformer le monde de l'agriculture
le kenza est produit sur quelques
hectares dans le nord de l'état comme
ici sur la ferme de rugby
ces plans qui fauche ont été semées il y
a deux ans car le kenzan est une culture
vivaces qui produit du grain pendant
plusieurs années la culture des vivaces
et le nirvana de l'agriculture
aucun besoin de ce mini de labourer les
champs et nous produisons de la
nourriture cette nouvelle culture si
l'aboutissement de 50 ans de travail
pour bon nombre de chercheurs parmi eux
dans l'oise professeur d'agronomie à
l'université du minnesota
beaucoup de gens affirmait qu une vivace
ne pouvait pas consacrer une plus grande
part de ses ressources à la production
de semences
[Musique]
depuis des millénaires la culture de
céréales se fait à partir de plantes
annuelles sélectionnés pour produire une
seule récolte chaque année le cycle
recommence avec de nouvelles semences
[Musique]
or cette façon de produire de la
nourriture à une époque des normes sur
nos écosystèmes source de consommation
majeur de combustibles fossiles
l'agriculture est aussi la cause
principale de la pollution des plans
d'eau dans les années 80 des chercheurs
de pennsylvanie répertorie une centaine
de plantes vivaces qui pourrait se
prêter à la production de céréales à
grande échelle une plante se démarque la
groupie intermédiaire introduites sur le
continent comme culture de fourrage
la groupe intermédiaire a été choisi
pour la grosseur de sagan et sa
résistance aux rigueurs de l'hiver
en plus le gré à bongo test gold
le gré à une forte teneur en protéines
en calcium et en oméga 3
en plus la plante est excellente pour la
santé des sols alors que les racines de
plantes annuelles comme le bli ne
pénètre qu environ un mètre dans le sol
la groupe here le réseau complexe de
racine qui peut atteindre 5 mètres de
profondeur
cela aide à prévenir l'érosion du sol et
à réduire la pollution de la nappe
phréatique
non seulement la banque utilise moins
d'azoté mais en plus le système
racinaire l'absorbent presqu'entièrement
pendant une dizaine d'années les
chercheurs croiser des milliers de
spécimens dagrou pire pour obtenir les
qualités désiré taille des grains
solidité de la tige force des racines le
garder des racines fortes pour assurer
la pérennité de la plante tout en
augmentant la taille de la grêle en 2013
dans l'oise a en fait sous la main une
première variété des groupies recréer
pour la production agricole
on l'appelle qui en a
c'est dans le nord de l'état qu'au lieu
les premiers essais cochon nous
cultivons des vivaces dans cette région
depuis longtemps comme le trèfle et
d'autres herbes
l'un de nos principaux problèmes c'est
l'humidité élevée du sol au printemps
qui peu retardé les semis avec les vivas
j'ai risqué plus faibles puisqu'elles
sont déjà dans le sol à l'automne 2014
ils s'aiment premier champ de kenza sans
trop savoir à quoi s'attendre
entre temps à l'université du manitoba
dog et annie veut créer une variété de
kenza bien adaptée au climat canadien
l'agro pire intermédiaire est utilisé
comme fourrage depuis des années même si
certaines variétés résistantes aux
hivers on se demande si elles sont
capables de produire du grain de façon
constante
en cours de route son travail de
sélection est facilitée par la météo
benoît 'ft' cette série d'événements
nous a fait perdre 60% de nos fans par
contre nous savons que ceux qui ont
résisté sont adaptés à notre presse
et
à l'été 2015 au sud de la frontière rich
man est l'un des premiers producteurs
américaine a récolté un champ de kenza
j'ai été surpris de la voir sans racines
et aussi rapidement et poussé avec une
telle vigueur
nous avons une très bonne récolte dès la
première année
ses voisins et lui produisent onze mille
kilos de kenza cette première année une
partie du grep est acheté par une
brasserie artisanale qui produit une
bière ou kenza mais la vraie question de
beurre la céréale se prête elle à la
production de nourriture
[Musique]
minneapolis métropole qui était au 19e
siècle la capitale mondiale des
meuneries dans cette boulangerie
artisanale stif retenu est l'un des
premiers à créer avec du grain qu'il
obtient des fermiers du nord de l'état
une farine de kenza
l'arôme et fabuleux terrain avec des
notes de noix
mais la farine ne ressemble pas du tout
à ce que les consommateurs connaissent
voici de la farine de blé roux de
printemps que l'on utilise pour certains
nos pains vous voyez que la couleur et
la consistance sont bien différentes de
la farine de kenza 76
outre la couleur particulière latin et
du grain de kenza est un défi il est
cinq fois plus petit que celui du blé ce
n'est pas idéal pour faire du pain on
utilise donc un mélange de farine
conventionnelle environ 85 pour ça avec
15 ou 20 % de farine de grains entiers
de kenza
malgré cela la l'immense suscite
beaucoup d'intérêt
au bout d'chou de café le chef daniel
schmitt concocte différents mais avec du
kansas je l'étais dans le pain les
craquelins les tortillas les pâtisseries
même y n'est pas tant le goût du
kentucky et la philosophie des céréales
qui me motive et six clients
l'apprécient
les ventes de produits faits avec la
céréale ne font qu'augmenter
[Musique]
ailleurs en ville l'entreprise doctrine
strand fabrique des pâtes fraîches avec
de la farine de kenza les arrivages de
kenza sont très irréguliers alors nous
nous produisons que quelques fois par
année mais la céréale suscite beaucoup
d'intérêt souvent les gens font la queue
le matin et tout se vend en moins d'une
heure mais il ya un hic la farine de
kenza coûte 5 fois plus cher que celles
de blé en raison des stocks limités
le marketing est donc ralenti par une
production très modeste
[Musique]
les chercheurs de l'université du
minnesota mise sur des rencontres comme
celle ci pour assurer l'avenir de la
céréale des ateliers dans les
communautés rurales où il rencontre les
fermiers les élus et les entrepreneurs
ces municipalités ne sont pas choisis au
hasard
l'agriculture conventionnelle n'est plus
soutenable ici les taux de nitrates dans
leurs nappes phréatiques sont très
élevés certaines communautés ont même
été obligés de construire des usines de
traitement d'eau potable ce qui
entraînait des dépenses de plusieurs
millions de dollars
les promoteurs de la céréale sont
convaincus que le kenzan pourrait être
une piste de solution au problème
grandissant de pollution des sources
d'eau potable
mais selon eux ce n'est pas aussi simple
que de faire pousser davantage de kenza
pendant longtemps de développer des
nouvelles du à la va vite ce qui n'a
jamais rien donné
il faut s'assurer que toutes les étapes
de production soit en place le séchage
le décorticage et l'entreposage du grès
mais aussi les contrats avec d'éventuels
clients
[Musique]
fin de l'été 2010 8 un moment que doc
cutanée attend depuis plusieurs années
où
la récolte sur l'épée recèle
expérimentale de l'université du
manitoba de la toute première variété
canadienne de kenza
[Musique]
ce grain servira à semer une trentaine
d'hectares de kenza sur des fermes
manitobaine à l'automne 2010 9 d'ici dix
ans j'espère voir naître une production
de queiroz a qui atteindrait les 2000 à
4000 hectares
[Musique]
au canada comme aux états unis le
travail génétique se poursuivra pour
améliorer la culture de la céréale
car malgré les succès des dernières
années les champs de kenza produite à
l'heure actuelle trois fois moins que le
blé si une plante vivace souhaite un
jour détrôner les géants de
l'agriculture conventionnelle
il faudra d'abord qu'elle fasse ses
preuves auprès de ceux qui la
cultiveront non point il faut une
certaine productivité car les gens
cherchent la rentabilité
[Musique]